dans l'est de l'Ukraine entre isium et
Liman un chapelet de village détruit il
se trouvait sur la ligne de front ils ne
sont plus que ruines
et pourtant partout des habitants ont
choisi d'y rester comme Maria David and
Co une miraculée
bombardée deux fois qu'elle est depuis
un peu sourde car elle n'était qu'à cinq
pas
sa vie ici n'est pas facile son mari est
mort sa fille est partie en Allemagne et
elle manque de tout
gaz d'eau ni d'électricité
explique-t-elle et tout l'argent de ma
pension sert à acheter du bois de
chauffage
alors Maria dépend presque entièrement
pour sa survie de l'aide humanitaire
comme elle tous les habitants de
drobi-chevet convergent donc une fois
par semaine vers le bureau de Poste du
village transformé pour l'occasion en
centre de distribution
cette aide est essentielle explique
Nadia bravova parce qu'avec la guerre on
a passé l'été caché dans nos caves et on
n'a pas pu cultiver nos champs ni faire
de provision
l'aide est une initiative personnelle de
demi-tour
originaire de la région il est attaché
aux gens du coin et ne pouvait se
résoudre à ne rien faire
les petits villages comme celui-ci ont
beaucoup souffert dit-il mais il n'y a
pas beaucoup de monde pour venir les
aider dans les grandes villes les
boutiques et les marchés sont ouverts à
joue-t-il mais ici il n'y a rien
tous les jours il recommence donc le
même manège à bord de son fidèle camion
transpercé des cladobus il fait le plein
de pain de boîte de conserve et de
produits de première nécessité et entame
une tournée des villages à proximité de
la ligne de front
des journées entières à sillonner des
routes peut recommandables et dans
chaque village il était accueilli comme
le Père Noël
et c'est comme ça partout je vais dit-il
quand on arrive partout où l'on voit
l'horreur la peur et la douleur on
essaie de changer ça pour des sourires
un an après le début de l'évasion russe
une chose est devenue très claire pour
tout le monde ici la guerre est loin
d'être terminée pour tenir le coup il ne
suffit donc pas de remplir les ventres
il faut aussi donner du baume au coeur
et pour soutenir le moral des
populations de métro s'est adjoint les
services d'un clown venu d'Italie un
spectacle organisé dans un sous-sol qui
a longtemps servi d'abris au programme
farcies et tour de magie devant un
auditoire conquis
[Musique]
c'est génial de voir des enfants sourire
la plupart de ces gamins n'avaient
auparavant jamais vu de clown
ce qui est plus important pour moi
dit-il sais-tu citer les merveillement
quand ça se produit pendant une
demi-heure les enfants oublient la
guerre pour
toute
et pour faire durer la distraction une
distribution de cadeaux des jeux et des
jouets pour chacun d'eux
une initiative financée entièrement par
la population au même titre que les
dents de nourriture pas de la charité
aux yeux de métro mais plutôt un
investissement dans l'avenir de
l'Ukraine pour cultiver l'espoir dans un
pays qui en a bien besoin